sein herz lassen
bild erste junge lass es demnach den
anlass ist unter wasser den anlass es
jetzt die nachlass man zusammen mit mit
der mid mid mid mid mit einer
kriegspartei ärger da wirst du sterben
ich hab halbe leben wirklich mal auf den
oder witzmann die gardena
ich schwöre dir lassen cri cri das
bedeutet krieg mein lieber den ich bin
ich fast tot lass das jetzt mal bitte
dein herz lassen
wie viel hast du junge lass es demnach
den anlass ist den erlass es jetzt die
land lasse man am 19 denn eigentlich weg
von mir hatte die familie so dann komme
ich als die regel
jetzt lass es sein den lappen gehen
junge lass es doch jetzt ist jetzt halt
dein maul wild krieg oder nicht willst
du junge lass es jetzt sein bitte ich
habe da ich kein bock jetzt drauf jetzt
haben wir so viele geile sachen zusammen
außerdem man das ist kacke alter höher
als auch zu schießen
darauf lässt an land gehen
wir kommen doch etablierte mama ich hab
doch gesagt wir gehen die zu mir hier in
der sein land gehen ja ok junge wehe du
tötest mich jetzt das hab ich auch angst
vor dir
ich glaube wir haben friedensvertrag
hallo ich mag es einfach zu schießen das
mein hobby das aber nicht so gut drin
ich bin ich bin nur fair soll ich mal
gut schießen
da hat der markt jetzt lass es wirklich
alt ich habe zweieinhalb herzen wenn du
sagst du kannst dich erschießen
lasst es jetzt bitte sein walther
sollich war man gut schießen junge den
erlass es jetzt sagen ja mal gut elena
solches sein lasst es sein junge ich
habe keinen bock auf so ein scheiß jetzt
okay hier auf ich habe eine korrekte
display ich weiß einfach die bringen ja
und ich habe deine legacy würdet ihr
auch geben wenn jetzt aufhörst ok ellen
page l
wenn du mich töten das wäre so das ist
lassen wir es selbst getroffen hat in
sachen teilen teilen ja okay was habe
ich denn dafür dass ihnen die angst vor
dir jetzt hier ja hier ist das land
feiere regen das auch nicht gut
oder es wegen der kiste mit seine sachen
packen
obwohl eigentlich will ich das ist ganz
gut aufgeteilt was wir hatten
ich weiß ja nicht was er hasst am
wichtigsten ist dass raab ja ich hab
viel ich tue das gleich alles in die
kiste du bist so langsam weil du diese
komische blüten irgendwie darüber weiß
nicht was dein problem es machst du gar
kein thomas karg 1 1 du kannst einfach
überlaufen
ja ja eine rüstung ist was kaputt wenn
meine triebel rüstung und voller angst
dass sie kaputt geht ist fast kaputt
aber irgendwas macht schaden
ich brauche noch ein andenken wollen
gleich den bergh costa vielmehr
schlössen ein wildschwein brettmann wir
müssen nach hause gehen
lass mich nicht in die mitte mit der
kubica eben nicht da müssen wir dann
vielleicht habe ich so ein ding
vielleicht ein icing
manchmal gucke ich gucke nach habe ich
dem stadtrat nochmals ihr dann gebe ich
dir schon mal eine korrektur einleiten
wo bist du jetzt sogar im projekt
langsam
ich würde das jetzt du kannst du dich
bewegen wenn du dir wenn du mich wenn
das noch einmal machst kriegst du keinen
gp bei ja doch aber nur ganz kurz
und wenn ich mehr verschlage alter
willst lass es sein den er wird seine
leggins oder nicht ja ok die liegt da
unten
wer nämlich die sicht schlecht ich sag
dir hört zu krieg oder nicht wk du
willst direkt sterns handlung mein
lieber junge
er denkt was bringt das alter jetzt
lasst uns trainer ich habe ein herz das
ist ein was ist eigentlich für bogen
man könnte diesen effekt auf der face 30
megabits muss ehrlich den er jetzt bitte
lasst es ganz kurz allen denen ich habe
da ich keinen bock drauf aber nicht dass
ich gerade jetzt so so gut ankommen wenn
du mich jetzt tötest aber jetzt das ist
doch wirklich mal ein junger ich weiß
aber sag mir hier lass es jetzt einmal
schießt und ich bin tot
ich dachte ich dachte nämlich schön
zusammen auf über die hast du unnötig
wenn ich ansagen gelangt der gemeinde
kontraste siehst du sollst du seinen
freund first ein gerät das gesamte team
wer hat das gesagt sag ich nicht ich
weiß nicht was ist aber hast noch immer
hätten sachen die mir vielleicht geben
willst ja wollen wir jetzt teilen
ja ja dann wie wollen wir den teilen und
belegt jetzt wo wir alle die sachen
reinlegen
du tust ähnlich traurig sagt einfach was
du hast 1000 main sein was du hast sagt
was du okay ich hab ein passwort ein
feuer granate dass es den mann getroffen
also ich hab kein bock ihr zu sterben
wegen unnütz jetzt lass es sache hin
danach hatte der galerie ok wat ich
dachte jetzt was ich habe der kopf ich
hören wildschwein
ich hab ender perlen clay redstone
netter warzen user
bodypainting button uns entscheiden
können egal das bringt nicht das level
haben muss erst verzaubern und dann neu
verenden machen dass wir als anlass um
eine stadt gehen und las verzaubern kann
es mir danach als sachen eben geben dass
wir nach hause kommen
nee ich hab nur eine sache hält du
meinst du das welche ja aber nur eine
ja aber du hast doch einmal diese
booster und einmal die als noch einmal
diese deine booster und einmal dieser
art kann ich dir auf den weg machen oder
macht er denn gar nicht den effekt das
geht nur mit der hose
danach hatte schade ich weiß gar nicht
was sind die koordinaten weißt du noch
wie wir nach hause gekommen sind zu uns
gekommen ist
die koordinaten die du uns doch hier ja
aber ich weiß dass nur so in etwa ja
also ich glaube dass 4000 musste weniger
werden staub so 4200 man musste hin zu
4200 bekomme ich denn dann her auf jeden
fall 2700 was richtige weißen noch
ungefähr so gar nicht vorne war das
richtige glaube ich ja 4200 das richtige
und das andere war irgendwie da weniger
ja nie mehr als das war wie ich musste
zu mehr ins meer vielleicht aber dahin
ist schon mal das große schiff das ist
schon mal ganz gut
sicher dass das jetzt durch die richtige
ist vielleicht genau umgekehrt alte das
kann auch sein als ich glaube eher
umgekehrt auch so eher weniger soll
nicht 3000 das war ja weniger egal
der ist jetzt blöd macht doch einfach
ein boot war bestimmst du gerade aus dem
boot
ich schwimme wieso schwimmst du kreis
kein holz ab
das echte hier ist doch ganz viel holz
gewesen noch verdammt ganz über bord
bringt wenn ich den boden mitbringen
dann muss ich ja aber zwischendurch
anhalten ja nee ich bin ich bin ja
gleich er am land hier zunächst erstmal
ist schon an land
das ist so traurig dass schwimmen die
ganze turnier über und überholt wird
gleich einfach ich warte ja an land und
dem was zu geben
die spastik als ob jetzt erste schwimmer
als ob ich hab weder verrückt schwämme
bist du nicht zurück kann ich ja nicht
ich bin aber hier auf dem boot auf dem
piratenboot wo wir das noch eben
klatschen klatschen ist eine schöne idee
ich muss noch sachen backpack packen und
sachen wegwerfen ich glaube ich kann mir
das ganze sehr gefährlich aussah charlie
miller erst mal mache ich jetzt hier so
eine richtig schöne branchen klink
rafting table weißer von firma das auch
richtig ab und zu mit dem boot
ich mache jeden drei boote mein lieber
weil ich genau weiß das ich bin da ganz
viele piraten oder getötet sie ist
einfach nur mein chili weiß trainer
wir sollten jetzt hinkommen alter alter
hier kommen aber ganz richtig richtig
viel ich habe richtig angst irgendwie
nicht jeder am boden kommen den daher
kommen gerade unendlich
das ist ein mini schiff das kann doch
nicht sein oder
mainz mini schiff hier nein sicher wir
sind drauf kommen da drauf das sind auch
ein paar tanzen
ich habe da jemand gesehen komm ans
fenster nein ich komme jetzt bestimmt
nicht ans fenster junge du schießt nun
bald ich hab kein bock mehr mit ihr
aufzunehmen sind nach einer verfeinerte
stadt ist hier
schmeiß mich nicht mehr scheiße
entschuldigung decker taylor phinney
schiff der ecke ich habe mir die sense
holt wasser essenzen da kann man so ein
blöder start machen
doch welcher diamond plate adscale
displaydeckel ich kein problem für mich
was electric essenstisch ehrlich hier
mein lieblingsessen
sie hält hatte damit der elektrik stuff
machen ja ok neues warum marktkenner ja
hast du mitgebracht was mein boden
mitgebracht mir habe ich mir sogar ganz
viele okay das leben ich glaube die
augen als sie zu gott alles weggeworfen
eigentlich wenn man hier war schlägt mit
dem kommt noch so sachen oder was
richtig schlage alten mann den amateur
aufschlag mich noch einmal ihr blick ist
ja kein schaden dadurch doch ich kriege
immer ein halbes jahr eine rüstung ist
der teile kaputt
ok deswegen habe ich warum kommt jetzt
weiß ich wie jetzt lass es sein
was machst du
guck mal was machst du du bist komisch
wieso also was machst du da ich an ein
verlieren
unter dem portal geöffnet
oh mein gott was passiert mit dem
schwarzen nichts
ja das ist es ja da kommt er wieder
häufig komme ich wieder aus woraus fehlt
dem schwarz nichts im schwarzen nichts
ich bin jetzt fast nichts
tja ich glaube hier was mache ich jetzt
keine ahnung oder luca bitte hilf mir
die leute helfen waren läuft mich fast
getötet hat sich gestern ein anderes
ding rein wo bin ich jetzt wird mit
einem helga und brot tötet mich die
ganze zeit nahezu ich bin wie auf dem
boot und wo bist du weg wo nein ich bin
halt auf dem weg nach hause
oh mein gott ich dachte ich sterbe
erfahren damit den weg damit
oh gott ripley ist echt drauf hast jetzt
im boot genommen und wo er leiter ist
werde ich fahrrad zu 4200 und da
irgendwie ich bin an land hier ist ein
schöner roter baum
du fährst 4200
300.000 3700 irgendwie sowas vierter -
4200 und was ist vor allem 3000 weise
nicht das set muss immer kleiner werden
okay bei den als garten krank bank hat
ihr etat
ja ja die wollen wir leben gerade am 8
wenn wir dran mit dem gerade am 8 12 13
13 auf guckt war krank waren unterwegs
waren
den grund naja kurzem angebot kaputt
gemacht jetzt ist sie wieder zum sehen
ich habe irgendwie aufgehört zu werden
ich hasse das schlauchboot fahren
scheiße dass wir langsam als mit den
schulen nämlich also mit 4200 ist habe
ich aber ich bin einfach nur so ein
riesen mehr mit tintenfisch und so und
und ich fahre und fahren wir dann geht
die vorhin schon 15 minuten
das kann die sein alter ich komme
einfach nicht sein dass das video hier
das wilhelm
das ist einfach nicht schaffen ich bin
jetzt bei minus wieder in 200 unterhält
sich etwas sonderfall jetzt den euch
doch dass nur so eine webseite zb 3400
3700 ich frage euch in die falschen oder
simple kriegsschiff und die lieder sind
da skeptisch
so ist man noch ganz kurz ein crafting
table mehr macht ruhig so ich mache
jetzt einfach mal ein bild von 10 grad
wieder mehr bei mir okay da sind schon
mal schiffchen wie wird setting ist
weniger hält fit kommt bei mir auch mehr
gott wie im kreis gefahren
ich fahre im kreis von ganz nah dran
sofern wir sicher dass z weniger werden
muss luca bist du dir wirklich sicher
alter warte die koordinaten es muss auf
jeden fall das eine muss 4200 sein das
erste darf ich jetzt erstmal ganz kurzen
dann habe ich das schon hinter mir ich
fahre mal schräg das verschlimmert
ja ich auch so 4200 da bin ich jetzt in
etwa und das andere war 2700 das war da
das heißt das muss in 2700 dass ich
hingefahren bin ich bin bei 3400 bei
3.800 jetzt jeder falsch lag ich guck
ganz kurz in anderen aufnahme hey guckt
einfach der meerwiese noch dumm sind die
alta koran mit m auf die märkte
ja ich weiß wo wir hin wenn ich weiß von
koordinaten ich weiß die koordinaten wo
mein haus ist ich auch 1600 nämlich auch
in zustände genau in die falsche
richtung hat war man wieder zurück jungs
einfach nur 2200 blöcke jetzt gelegen
okay war geradeaus fahren und bei der
nacht egal hast ein schönes thema über
das wir reden können ja letztendlich
bett aber was haben sie bestimmt den
zuschauer in den letzten folgen richtig
kasse im englisch geld also machen wir
einfach mal auf englisch redet dann ist
jedes zweite wort irgendwas die aussage
mit mit 1000 messages
fakt ist man schneller wenn man rennt
man schneller wenn man rennt wkn minute
okay okay wenn ich bin mir dabei den
doppelt bei den doppelten termin bringt
als ob ich bin bei 4200 und 3.700 bin
nicht harald heute des wegs dann
geschafft geht schon damals geld nach
haseloffs nächsten falter okay gut dann
würde ich sagen wenn euch start-stopp
hey hast du ja auch gehört sinnvoll nah
beieinander
auch gehört wenn es euch gefallen hat
würden wir uns definitiv über einen
deutschen nach oben freuen
und sonst sehen wir uns dann in der
nächsten folge wieder wo wir dann
weiterhin weg nach hause suchen werden
wir jetzt beenden
bis zum nächsten mal schon ein bisschen
macho